foreign
foreign
foreign
the three Muslims today we're joined
with another very special guest if you
guys recognize them this because he is
the man himself productivity athletes
how you doing today
I'm doing very well
asking and how you guys doing
I gotta ask you bro what's with the mask
I had a feeling that was coming uh
sooner rather than later
um I began the
I just generally didn't like being known
um even before this
um I was gonna do streaming for
as a living at one point
um even though I didn't go far too far
in it
um I always like to be mossed I just
prefer being unknown and wanting to just
do whatever I can whilst I do it so I
kind of took that on when I started
business and I started my Instagram with
um just pretty much hiding my face and
then I kind of become known for it so I
just pretty much had my face online I
don't do it in public obviously but um
online I just prefer to keep it that way
um it gives me a sense of privacy and if
anyone does recognize me although that
doesn't happen often at least they know
because he wears a mask they'll give me
that sense of privacy because they see
it online already
um it's like uh
I was gonna say something but it would
be dumb for me to say no but man may
Allah bless you that's that's honorable
especially since like when you get into
the online sphere and you started you
know showing your face it's it can go
sideways very quickly
no it does it does definitely
100 percent
today inshallah everyone stay tuned
because uh later on around 7 PM EST
we're gonna have a Brother come on uh
and say hey alhamdulillah this is I lost
count of how many already he's found a
lot
um may Allah allow it you know to may
Allah allow our brothers and so Allah to
keep accepting Islam and our sisters
keep accepting Islam and I mean continue
to bless with the honor of being the one
to do inshaallah
it's amazing
So today we're going to be talking about
something that a lot of people struggle
with me I'm sure on Helen Abdullah at
one point also struggle with this and
that is productivity being productive so
firstly Abdullah why don't you tell us
what it means to be productive when you
name yourself productivity athlete what
does that mean
the name itself was just a marketing
scheme it's just a catchy name and plus
the word productive um at the time I
guess it wasn't in notion as much but um
as um Instagram and Tick Tock grew um
and everyone just showing off their
routines and everything the notion of
productivity is growing so when someone
sees the word productive it just
naturally brings them towards my channel
um which I guess has helped with the
growth of it as well so productivity can
have many different meanings and
obviously from an Islamic point of view
it's very different to what it would
mean outside an Islamic point of view
but in general if you give like a
generic definition it would just be to
do the right thing at the right time at
an efficient rate and um obviously that
could be broken down even more than that
but that would just be like a simple
definition to give towards productivity
okay all right beautiful definition
alhamdulillah how do you say most people
struggle with productivity today do you
would you say there's a common uh reason
that a lot of people struggle with it
um yeah I believe the genuine common
reason revolves around just
understanding their roles and
responsibilities and um obviously
Society has a certain demand of us
whereby you need to be uh
you need to go for a certain school
system you need to be married at a
certain age or at least be interested in
some of that particular age have kids at
a certain age and do things in a
systematic way and it doesn't adjust or
it doesn't tailor towards people's
circumstances and I think that's where
the problem is like I've dealt with
different clients whereby someone may be
dealing for example with a disabled
family member now that by default now
they're in a lifestyle whereby a few
hours of their days taken out not
because they want to but out of force
and obviously they're willing to because
of it's their family member to look
after that family member
um who has that um condition where
someone else may not have the same uh
you can say responsibility and therefore
they have more time and that person when
they first met me they felt really bad
because they said a few hours of my days
go gone every day and I don't know what
to do with um I feel like I'm wasting my
life away so obviously after speaking to
them and everything you'd let them know
that something like that is very
productive we need people in society who
will sometimes they're not they're not
in front of the camera they're not show
in the world what they're doing but
they're looking after their family in
such a manner and other people they
don't have any responsibilities so
they're free to do what they want and
they're free to do the decisions they
like so if you give one system to
everyone it's not necessarily going to
work
absolutely absolutely on her bro you
have a comment on it yeah I was gonna
say that it's um it basically goes to
show that it's the end result the end
goal that we're actually looking at you
in terms of like the productivity are
you serve the responsibility of
understanding what your responsibility
is because if this person if they were
to say oh well my responsibility is uh
opening up a business and then now
they're put into this position
they're going to struggle big time to be
able to accept the fact that they're
still being productive just
in a different way yeah
yeah 100 I think also a really big
aspect
um of people not being productive is the
fact that we have everything which is
very easy everything's very convenient
for us in our life
um you know if I want to eat if I'm
hungry I could just pull up my phone and
call a pizza shop and have food
delivered to my house you know it
doesn't take a lot of me being
productive unless you consider me
pulling up my phone and making a call
productive you know things are really at
our fingertips so I think we've become
accustomed to this very simplistic and
easy and lazy frankly lifestyle so
people don't want to push themselves to
go to the gym they don't want to push
themselves to learn more and do things
that you know are not as fun as you know
watching a movie or a show or playing
video games or something like that
what do you say actually I think it's a
good question would you say that once
you got more productive in life assuming
at one point you weren't very productive
like a lot of young men out there would
you say that once you got more
productive that you stopped playing
games as much stopped watching movies as
much and kind of all that stuff in your
leisure time
absolutely so I'll try I'll try my best
to answer this question in like a more
comprehensive manner so I I'm a big gay
man that's pretty much what I did with
my life is mainly games I wasn't really
big a fan of going out and mingling too
much I'd rather just do all my uh
entertainment was just pretty much just
gaming so you're right as I got more
productive I definitely had to play less
however I did find free research and
through obviously personal experiences
and also dealing with clients a very
very important part of life is leisure
and but it's productive Leisure and what
that means is you need to find something
that suits your sort of lifestyle and
doesn't go against it like I'll give you
an example let's say an athlete an
athlete works most of their days in the
gym or start training with their team or
doing whatever is suited depending on
the athlete they are whether they're
tennis player whether they're footballer
whatever it may be now that athlete
can't go home
and for example snack and just they can
watch a movie let's say but they can't
watch a movie and just eat popcorn and
junk because that's going to deteriorate
them for the next day or for the next
time they go up whereas the average
person let's say he doesn't enter five
can watch a movie and snap because it's
not going to affect their nine to five
so what I did learn is I need to find
Leisure that complements my life and
doesn't go against my lifestyle and that
was what the big shift for me was is
that I needed to find something that
when I do relax it actually does make me
feel relaxed and doesn't deteriorate me
so when I go into the next day I don't
feel like my mind's all over the place
and I need to start all over again
especially when dealing with clients and
dealing with a with human beings
I need my head to be quite leveled and I
can't be someone who's uh quite down or
weak I need to be at at most a very
positive person when you're dealing with
people and trying to uplift them and
trying to change their lives so I needed
to change my leisure in that way but as
you said you definitely do need to
reduce in Leisure because when you over
indulging it you're obviously just
pretty much just constant in constant
dopamine and that's what makes you lazy
in the first place because when you work
it's never going to provide you with as
much dopamine or when you do anything of
that is not Leisure or or entertainment
you're not you're not getting as much
dopamine and therefore you're never
going to feel the same amount of fun and
you're always gonna have some form of
resistance towards it whether it's gym
or studying or anything of the like
you know I could see that what
recommendations would you give in terms
of like activities of leisure that are
productive
it really I it genuinely genuinely
depends from person to person like a lot
of people get surprised when I say game
yeah I'll tell you why your gaming is so
good if you're someone here if you're
super busy and can't leave your house
much but when I keep Brotherhood then
find a group of brothers who who you can
play games with like I know there's
these group of brothers they're libyans
um and they've formed a great
relationship between two different
cities and now they'll go meet each
other from City to city and they're very
they have very strong Brotherhood and
they won't leave their houses that much
because they prefer not to leave it as
much because of the fitness and they'd
rather and socialize within their houses
than outside their houses or at least
more commonly and that was their way of
uh socializing and maintaining a
Brotherhood whilst also maintaining
their lives are not really overly
indulgent in that Leisure and then first
but um
as they're just a blanket statement it
would be very very hard it'd literally
generally be in accordance to each
person's lifestyle I would just have to
look at the individual Criterion just be
like this is what would suit person to
person but I definitely think
socializing as a whole and keeping good
companionship is is very good
yeah later
it kind of makes me think right because
there are
is this what we're talking about there's
certain case scenarios with each person
but then there are certain things where
it's like let's say it's a new skill
that this person may want to learn or
maybe they don't even know they want to
learn it but they probably should learn
it
um at first if it's something that they
don't want to do then it's not really
going to be seen as leisure
um even if they do want to do it they're
still learning like fresh first so it's
not going to be full full Leisure uh but
do you feel like this can also be
something that that can move in that
direction to become Leisure for them so
if someone's learning like a new skill
and wants to turn it into basically
something they enjoy a lot more
I think yeah because I think most things
when we start as human beings you're
never ever going to be good at anything
and when they say oh this person is a
naturally talented I do believe in it to
an extent but you're also it was learned
Talent as well so you would have learned
it somewhere um at one point in your
life you can't just wake up in the
morning and just suddenly you know what
I'm so good at this thing it must have
originated from somewhere at one point
so and because of that
most of the fun is after you'll learn it
in something so even like people at
school or you can say people call them
nerds the reason they enjoy their
subject isn't necessarily because the
subject is fun it's because they're so
good at it and the more you're good at
something the more you like it because
you feel confident within it whoever
kind of makes you feel confident you're
gonna try to be around it as much as you
can and that's what you can say that's
what would make someone like enjoy their
um they work a lot more if they're good
at it and they feel they see some form
of comfort they see confidence in it and
some form of objective in it
yeah interesting
yeah let me um let me jump in real quick
just because a lot of people in the chat
are distracted because uh one person
who's spamming something and I just want
to clear it up inshallah for a quick
second
um there's this person
saying that like I'm a part of Hezbollah
and that's a horrible thing and blah
blah blah because we we talk about
hilafa and that stuff firstly I'm not a
part of even if I was I don't know why
it's such a big deal
um I disagree with some of their methods
but it's not like there are a whole
other religion and also he said
my last name's not even Khalil
um it's a stage name so I mean that's
really sad but um yeah regardless every
Muslim the world wants and I'm gonna
block you because you cause a lot of
fitna in the chat regardless let's get
back to the main topic inshallah so we
can be productive during the stream we
got two comments um Stella says I've
been lazy uh today and
um brother Ron I'm coming for you guys
listen with what with your level of
productivity you're not going to run and
go after anyone but he says I'm 28 years
old and I've been lazy for 28 years
where would you start with advising you
know people who have been lazy the whole
day or their whole life with being more
productive
you're not allowed to say it depends on
the person no no no no no no there's
general advice there's definitely
general advice and and when it comes to
when it when it comes to being when it
comes to being productive I think you
just there's definitely there's you need
to start somewhere and if you want your
productivity to last because you can
give someone the general routine which
is definitely just start hitting the gym
or hit some form of exercise because
when your body feels a bit stronger you
have more energy naturally and the more
energy you have the more productive
you're going to be that's why working
out in the morning is very very healthy
for you because when you work out early
in the day it boosts one your dopamine
but also boosts your energy levels and
that's right and it lasts very long
those energy levels and that's why I
personally when I wake up in the morning
I prefer to go gym off the refrigerator
by a little bit I'll go to I'll go to
the gym and that's what I prefer to do
and how to start my day and then I'll
just immediately go to work after that
and I feel this sense of energy so
definitely like it would just have a
very basic routine and that's my advice
to everyone like if you've seen my
Instagram from day one when I had no
followers to when I've had followers
that advice has been the same have have
a very bad routine and what I mean by
that is tell yourself you're going to
wake up at a certain time even if it's
late that's no problem tell yourself
you're going to go to the gym even if
it's for 10 minutes tell yourself you're
gonna sleep late even if
um even if sleeping late is bad the
problem the the problem is not the
routine that's bad
the problem is that people don't follow
what they say but when you begin to
follow something then now you tell
yourself you know what instead of
sleeping at 12 p.m I'm going to sleep at
11 30. you've trained your mind to
listen to yourself
loads of people what happens is they
tell themselves tomorrow 6am I'm gonna
wake up I'm gonna it's 20 23 I'm gonna
change and then they don't and that that
becomes a pattern until they realize I
can't take myself seriously and then
whenever they say anything they don't
follow their word so always advice
follow a bad routine so just make any
bad routine as I said sleep late wake up
late no problem but as long as you're
following yourself you're like you know
what I'm telling myself to wake up at 10
p.m 10 a.m I'm waking up at 10 A.M I'm
telling myself at sleep at 1am I'm
sleeping at 1am telling myself go gym 10
minutes I'm going to the gym 10 minutes
you build this philosophy within
yourself that if I say something I'm
gonna do it and then slowly from there
you begin to tweak it and make it a
really good routine and I think that's
the most practical method I can give to
someone who's at rock bottom
all right you know slightly off topic
but not really it's actually very on
topic but kind of off
um you have mentioned that you you work
out in the morning and you mentioned
that that's actually pretty nice because
you know it gets you energized and all
that question I have met what about
people who like to fast
you know because like you could still
work on the morning but it's like
technically if you work out and then you
stay in a fast state for
I don't know man let's see what got them
for you it's like 7 A.M and then you're
not gonna eat until maybe like
one two three four maybe five in the
afternoon
like I wonder if that's even productive
at that point
uh you you'll get into a bit more
technical in terms of uh when it comes
to uh that's why that's why I said it's
like not bad it's a it's a little off
from personal experience I don't think
fasting should affect one's ability in
terms of uh their their productivity too
much in fact when you look into science
and everything and like when you look
into the benefits of fasting faster
should make someone more productive
because when you eat you fulfill one of
your desires and when you fulfill your
desire slowly what happens is you become
more lazy and I remember one of them a
scientists I can't remember his name but
he was given off the analogy of of uh
the hyenas he said they're always
they're always on the go because they're
always hungry and then if you look at a
lion after he has a stake or after he
has his food he's just relaxing he's
just sitting down and he's just chilling
so if you go in the morning and you're
fasting I if generally speaking if you
have just regular like you have regular
health so if you have health conditions
obviously it's a different story but if
you just have regular health and you
don't hit the gym whereby like you're
sweating you've done a crazy gym session
you've just gone there you may be done
34 40 minutes Waits maybe eight to ten
reps nothing too heavy just medium
weight whereby you can manage it and you
mainly go there because you're creating
energy back like that and then when you
go home you won't feel you won't feel
burnt out from it because you haven't
done a crazy workout so you're not going
to desire
um food as much as you would from a very
very hard workout if you're fasting then
obviously you'd be a bit more logical
and you're not going to go all out on
that day and you do it a lot less
it makes sense it makes sense because
the moment we eat it's like you said
it's psychological and it's also
physiological you know you the blood has
to go to your stomach to digest the food
whereas you have less blood in your in
your brain so you can't you can't think
as clearly so the productivity does take
it here for sure and uh more levels than
we can even think of
um but it's just a genuine curiosity man
because you say working out and like I
love working out in the morning but I've
always like played with this idea was
like if I work out then I go all out and
then I have to eat to eat and then if I
eat I'm not as productive so it's like
should I just fast should I just work
out which one do they do
um so yeah forgive me both for being a
little off no no no that's cool that's
good we have a uh a message from Brother
Adam he says let's be honest most people
have a day job and cannot do these
things easily even myself a huge gym
person I found it hard to get my
workouts throughout the week with
full-time work
that's a
that's a fair point I actually work with
a lot of full-time people who work in
nine to five
um and this would all depend on a few
things one what are your
responsibilities after work like if you
come home to a family and you're there
like now you have to socialize with your
kids and you have to do a few things
then that would like obviously that
would take away your evening so you
can't really do for example gym in the
evening and
um if you commute very long then it
takes away your gym in the morning
unless you're willing to wake up really
early which most people won't be but
generally speaking most people let's
just say you have a few hours before
work instead of waking up at seven wake
up at 5 30 or 6 if you're really willing
to I'm committed to and you're quite
disciplined then you're able to go gym
in the morning and then from there and
you've given yourself that hour instead
of sleeping you're gone an hour into the
gym and then after work you can just
fully relax and I generally recommend
the nine to five is to do their workouts
before
um before work and not after work or
maybe during their break if they have a
local gym because when you do it after
workers you've already done a nine to
five you don't want to go and finish
work and then go to the gym and then it
becomes like a longer day of work
basically
that's a good point beautifully soon man
I was actually talking to one of my
clients and he had mentioned that uh we
all have more free time than what we
think
so it's like this person was saying that
they're not it's like
um also you know they should probably
like look at how much what are they
actually doing like how much free time
do they actually have the questions
sorry sorry go ahead no no feel free
I'll I'll remember my point
no no go ahead please no the question I
just generally asked like because most
people say they don't have time I just
ask one simple question what's your
screen time and no one's who I usually
ask that question to you their screen
times at least five hours
so I'm like yeah you can go to the gym
and that's genuinely I've had like my
average from what I've seen the most my
clients would begin with between to five
and I've seen up to 18 hours a day by
the way so I've seen extreme cases
and I would put some from time to time
I'll ask my followers like what's your
screen time and I don't think I've ever
seen anyone below five hours
and these are the same people by the way
DM me I have no time I need a routine oh
I need to do this I need to do that I
love the solutions Within by the way the
person themselves and just shifting a
few things
this is the same like I don't have time
for Quran I don't have time for Jim I
don't have time to study my Dean I don't
have time for
um my kids at another time your screen
time a lot of the times what's rubbing
you off your time
yeah 100 I genuinely think if someone
like you know had a flip phone for three
days or something like that and got rid
of their Electronics then they'd be a
lot more productive because I mean think
about if we don't have these things that
are constantly filling us with dopamine
and giving us dopamine spikes we'd find
pleasure we'd find enjoyment in doing
things like reading and learning and
building and and all that stuff I
genuinely think people would do those
things more naturally
um but I think another big point that
people don't utilize are naps you know
people can get away with like five six
hours of sleep if they nap
like I've had days and this wasn't
planned this is just how it went where I
woke up at like you know before just
before 7am for Fajr I stayed up I had
courses and classes and video recordings
and all these different things I took a
20 minute nap and by the way I slept at
2 A.M the night before so I I slept for
like four or five hours took a 20 minute
nap and I felt like I just slept the
whole night
different man
and it's the Sunnah of the Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam which leads
me to the next point or the next
question which is
how do we tie productivity with Islam
you know what about the people that say
you know I I pray my Salah and I read my
Quran and I you know I do my vicar and
I'm good why do I need to go out and do
other things and be productive in these
ways if I if I read my Quran
that's uh that's a great question well
um
Islam came to be Islam is a productive
religion and as a blanket statement and
there's a very clear statement Islam the
reason it's the truth is because it came
with everything and the truth has to
come of everything because if he's
missing anything that mankind needs it
can't be the truth because what you're
claiming is that this is the perfect way
in order for it to be perfect perfect
means there's nothing missing Islam has
not missed out anything and part of life
is productivity in fact the Key of Life
is productivity and if you're not living
productively then what is the amen of
the objective or what differentiates
people if it's not productivity the
reason why we're on different levels
comes down to productivity and comes
down to the person's willingness like if
you look at the sahaba like let's say if
you go back to Abu Bakr he used to
he used to go to an old lady's house he
was blind cook for her clean for her do
everything he would have attended a
funeral he would have given sadaka and
he would have prayed his crayon and then
it's only Fajr time people have only
woken up this guy's done good deeds that
people don't do in their whole lives
just in the morning on a frequent basis
this was just his life
and then this is why they say Abu Bakr
after the prophets
no man if he was put him on one side of
the scale and then put the rest of them
on the other side he would outweigh
everyone this is productivity because he
understood
the rights of the people and the rights
of Allah like let's say you memorize
Quran but then you don't benefit no one
you haven't actually benefited let's say
your neighbor or let's say your parents
or let's say even your colleagues or
whatever it is you haven't benefited
people then how are you being productive
productivity in Islam brings everything
together and this is the whole point of
Islam Islam wasn't a religion whereby
you stay in the house Allah sent us out
to enjoy the good and forbidden evil and
it becomes it's a very comprehensive
thing in fact there are actually there
are actual Islamic Sciences on
productivity it's just obviously not
titled productivity so if you look at
then you would find that there are
different stages
um and there are different levels of
productivity and one of the verses in
the in this poem called by Imam assadi
he mentions what happens when two good
come together and you have to choose
between the two so you can come to for
example right now you need to recite the
Quran but then your mom calls you
because you need to do grocery shopping
and this probably happens to people on a
regular basis and the common knowledge
is what that I'm going to just recite
hold on because I'm doing it bad I'll
tell my mom you know what next time or
something then your mom leaves the house
she does a grocery shopping and you're
just there reading Quran and this
happens
that's less productive because the to
recite the Quran is Sunnah whereas
helping your mother is obligatory but
then people don't know the differences
so if you don't know that then you can't
just tell me to sit at home and recite
Quran because then you're missing out on
what is really more productive
100 beautiful Point actually I think
about maybe six months ago my Sheikh
gave a a lecture
on he's in title the productivity but he
he spoke about being comfortable and
being uncomfortable and he spoke about
how all throughout the Quran and the
Sunnah comfort and sitting being
comfortable and having all this leisure
time and all that stuff is linked with
I'm at the very least I'm going to say
something negative if not you know
you're on the path to hell it's
literally linked with being on the path
to help and being uncomfortable and
working constantly and pushing yourself
is linked to the reward from Allah
growth development and Jannah and if you
look at the first ayat that came to the
process of Salaam
um even though he was in the State of
Shock It commanded him to go out and
warn
during the day to stand up all night in
prayer Allah didn't say take your time
digest take a break go take a nap Allah
said rise and warned get up the night
and and pray for most of the night
except for like uh a little bit that was
what Allah to do immediately be as
productive as possible subhanallah
like I even I actually had this up
because I had a feeling this was gonna
come do you guys know the
um the book I'm very sure you guys are
probably aware of it the book of um the
top hundred most influential men of all
time yeah by Michael Hedgehog yeah yeah
so I I'll just read the passage here
quickly from the bottom
um and and this is to do Muhammad and
this is the most productive man to ever
live because even when you look at his
lifestyle let's just say let's even if
you took away his Islam just him as a
character you would still say he's the
most productive man from how many wives
you had to looking off down a lot of the
time obviously it was maintenance what
he was doing for for the ummah and he
would look after
um the children he would look after the
society he would look after General
Affairs he would look after the
political Affairs he would look after
Army Affairs a man who's doing all of
this
if that is the person who is our role
model then you can't tell me that we
Layman should just be
um not productive if that's you were
aspiring to be like yes we will never be
on his level but that means we should be
aspiring to do something um to be as
good as him
so it says here
it is impossible for anyone who studies
the life and character of the great
prophet of Arabia
who knows how he taught and how he lived
to fill anything but reverence for the
mighty Prophet Muhammad
one of the great messengers of the
Supreme and although in what I put to
you I shall say many things which may be
familiar to many
yet I myself feel whenever I reread him
a new way of admiration in you and a new
way of reverence for the mighty Arabian
teacher and this is someone who's not
even Muslim and this is what he's saying
about Muhammad and when you obviously
look at um his summary of everything he
said you can't debate to me that this
person is not the most productive the
most influential man of all time when
him most people the other influential
men grew up in societies whereby there
are privileges which is another thing
when it comes to productivity and it's
kind of what we discussed in the
beginning people's circumstances can
impact someone but it doesn't limit them
and that's what maybe I didn't mention
it doesn't limit the person to oh no
this person may be in the camera and
you're behind scenes so the person in
the camera is better than you just by
default no you just have to use your
circumstances mama said I wasn't didn't
grow up in a society whereby he's
privileged like every other
um leader
um of the time if you grew up in a
society whereby it's a lot of Filth and
a lot of um Haram around him and a lot
of Trials yet he still managed to do
what he did and you've got to remember
really his life started at 40. so people
who are complaining that 28 my life I've
been lazy or people who are 30 or people
even 40 people even above his side is
life at 40 and for 23 years he managed
to achieve what he did achieve that no
man would ever achieve within 23 years
but it's still an inspiration and that's
how we should look at it as Believers we
should just look you know what what can
I do see my life as 60 years let's say
for example if I'm using my phone eight
hours a day and I'm sleeping eight hours
a day that's four years of my life gone
on automation sleeping and on my phone
now I have 20 years of my life if that's
if that's how you're going to end up
living then
you need to look at yourself and realize
that that's not how a man should be
living or a woman should be living I
should look at my life and see you know
what how am I going to fill up these 60
years and how am I going to be
productive for at least 60 years and
have a plan whereby every year I plan to
increase myself and a lot of the time we
we compare ourselves those people on
social media and people who've made it
um on camera
rather than competing with ourselves and
realizing okay this year I've memorized
wonders next year I'm going to memorize
another dress the year after I'm going
to memorize another juice but we'll look
at someone who's memorized the Quran in
five years and try and compete with them
whilst that's a good thing compete with
yourself first and once you get to a
certain level then compete with others
when you've reached their level
that's very beautifully said and it's
really easy for people to seem One Way
online this actually goes back to what
Anna mentioned before about people you
know seeming a lot more busy than they
are I think honestly from my experience
most people including myself at one
point who act so busy a lot of the time
are not busy at all they'll be busy like
three hours of the day and the rest
they'll feel busy while they're just
playing video games or watching a movie
or something that's like you can
literally do that any other point bro
come on so I think the same kind of
falls into when you see football online
you know
um people will rent a sports car and act
like they made all this money and bought
it and they own it and like you
shouldn't look at these people and
apostles on them he said don't look at
people who have more than you to look at
people who have less than you because
that will inspire one it may be a sense
of progress they're like okay at least
I'm not that bad or Allah
has not you know put me in in a worse
situation I'm better than some people
alhamdulillah and in regards to my
situation and um just kind of push from
there inshallah
I had a question
brother so let's say you have a client
they come to you and they tell you the
situation the whole life
and you basically deduce from speaking
with them that a very good activity of
leisure for them would be perhaps
uh playing video games would you say
that as for the example right but then
what if they say when you say that they
think for a second they say but what
about the prophet Muhammad and they use
his as him as an example and they say
how like he did all of these things and
here I am just gonna settle for playing
video games as a Leisure like shouldn't
I be doing more what would you say to
this individual
I'll answer two questions whilst you
asked one so one is that I'll never
really suggest um leisure time for
people what I usually do is they'll give
me their Leisure times because obviously
not everyone plays video games what I'll
usually do is they'll give me their
Leisure times and I'll just tell them
look out of what you've given me like
some people say I like to scroll through
social media and I think that should
just never just generally be a Leisure
thing if you went on it occasionally
okay but I don't think it should be a
Leisure thing and then they'll give me
other options of what or not options but
what other things they do they may watch
Netflix go out with their friends and I
look at the ones where I can see it's
the most healthy for them and then I
told them look you already do this just
do this at a higher level and then
eliminate other hobbies that aren't as
good as for you so I'll try to tell them
to eliminate social media eliminate
binge watching on Netflix so then you
have more control over your mind and
then go maybe go out with your friends
more or maybe go to a family gatherings
more or whatever it may be and to answer
the question whereby now if someone
listed it let's just say replies and
says oh you're telling me to to do one
of my hobbies but even that hobby
doesn't coincide with the Sunnah
um in terms of that the prophet Muhammad
didn't do it then I would say one you're
not Muhammad and two
I would say that
people a lot of people would say these
things but then when you don't give them
that option they go to a worse option
and that's very common so like you told
someone
um
I don't know like let's just say someone
has the opinion that
um
let's say someone's trying to get away
from music but then they also had the
opinion that you know what nasheeds are
bad I'm like brother like you you have
two options right now because you need
to leave according to you you really
need to listen to something you find
nasheed's Haram and you find music on
I'm obviously going to advise the person
to go for the lesser of the two evils at
that point so that's what you can say if
like if if I'm so called advising
someone towards something whereby
they're like you know what this is not
Sunnah by the end of the day each each
people would have their own ways of
entertainment like the sahaba how they
used to entertain themselves was they
this is one way obviously this is not
all the ways but one of the ways they
used to entertainment social was
obviously wrestling another way was that
they would have watermelon skins and
throw it at each other and that was
their way of entertainment we live in a
new era whereby we have new ways of
entertainment so you just gotta adjust
in accordance to your
um to your time we're very Advanced
right now so the way we interact is very
different to the way they interacted
especially for them knowledge was just a
normal thing because when you have a
profit like that around you all you're
going to want to do is going to want to
be
around
so you would do your best to to do that
so you can't really compare on that
level either
um
yeah 100 just to build off the power
firstly um would you be able to just
shift over to the left a little bit
uh yeah well sorry other way yeah I
think the camera's inverted but um yeah
perfect and I mean even the process he
had enjoyment the process telling me
said that this world the Dunya is
temporary enjoyment and the best and the
best of temporary enjoyment is a Pious
wife you know the process sounded like
he had his own form of enjoyment and and
Leisure Time or whatever
um even though he was the hardest
working man I saw some and there was one
scholar I forget who it was but he said
that uh he wanted to take a break to
kind of like you know get a little bit
of entertainment and stuff and he saw
two men I think carrying like a big log
and you know ones on each end and
they're they're both carrying it down a
certain path and because they're just
carrying a log they were doing this
thing where they would basically like
I guess freestyle and then after one
finishes the other one we continue with
the next line and try and rhyme it and
they would go back and forth right and
so the Sheikh was sitting there and he
was watching listening to them out of
enjoyment so there's nothing wrong with
that but this goes back to the point you
mentioned before which is looking at
someone who's like level like level 10
max level and you're at level negative
four and you're like
you know well the process said I didn't
do that he's level 10 it's like bro
Insha'Allah let's take it one step at a
time you know the Apostle salaam he
stood up all night in prayer you're not
just gonna start standing up all night
in prayer every single night you're not
gonna be able to do that and Apostle
himself actually discouraged others from
doing that he said I'm the prophet Allah
other people should not be doing you
know going to that level so all you have
to do is take it step by step build up
if you want to read 20 pages of Quran a
day there's nothing wrong with starting
five starting with ten and building your
way up because these habits have to be
built and they have to be formed they're
not something as much as I would love it
as much as anyone else would love it
we're not just going to wake up and be
the perfect person so the best thing and
what I advise Brothers to do is imagine
what the you know the best version of
yourself looks like and what's the
difference between you now and you then
and then every single week set standards
and goals so you get closer to that
inshaallah I think that's what people
should focus on
I'm surprised you didn't mention the uh
extreme
uh example
whereas like if you go into one extreme
then you're gonna dip into another
extreme oh yeah well like this guy is
saying oh I'm not gonna listen to music
but I'm also not going to listen to the
sheets because I think that's Haram as
well and it's like well then what are
you going to listen to bro like the
Quran all the time that's beautiful
that's a beautiful thing to aim towards
but if you're coming straight from music
that's tough
you know like you like you said you
might dip into something even worse
that is very true that is very true and
um
yeah a lot of the time when people are
in extreme they realize that they jump
all the way to the other end but uh you
know transformation doesn't happen it
doesn't happen overnight you know
changes don't happen overnight it's uh
maybe I change an attitude maybe a
change in Gold but not a change in habit
it takes 21 days to make it break a
habit you know not a change in character
not a change in who you are and what you
learn and understand all that takes time
inshallah yeah
it reminds me of that saying uh Rome
wasn't doing it one day
yeah very true very very true
trying to find some uh questions if you
guys have questions in the comments
please send them through Insha'Allah and
I will pull them up bit by bit
our brother says it is it is tough one
year in the dean and I'm still
struggling with music wow
um Allah he said that the love of Quran
and the love of Music cannot coexist
within the same heart and I will be the
first to say whenever I hear Quran
especially you know a nice recitation
that I like like Salman
I cannot get the recitation out of my
head and whenever I hear a song that's
catchy I cannot get that song out of my
head so I would say find a reciter you
love listening to
and I can recommend a few like I
mentioned Salman Ali utabi when told
salimi I'm sure people in the comments
inshallah can find some great ones for
you as well and listen to our citations
you like I promise it will it will
replace music like that inshallah
but Abdullah do you have any um any
advice for the brother
um
he's one year into the dean and he's
already thinking about this which is
already is phenomenal
um
the fact that you've asked the question
um shows already a sense of Iman in fact
it shows a strong level of Iman because
you're already one year in and you're
looking at everything that you could
possibly take out your life that's
negative and you're already proactive
with it so it already shows that your
head is in the right place and the fact
that your head's in the right place just
keep it there and even if you fall back
into it occasionally then alhamdulillah
because your head's already in the right
place
and because you're because you're still
early on and you're learning and you're
developing do your best to take it as
slowly as possible like this Dean is
strong and it's very very comprehensive
and you can never learn it in one day
nor can you even learn it in one year so
the best thing that you can do is take
it as slow as possible and be positive
as much as you can especially in the
beginning when it comes to your religion
when the more positive you are the more
motivated you are to do things like
we can everyone can criticize everything
for example you could wake up for fetch
uh towards the end of fridge and then
Chris has yourself to tell yourself you
know what I could have woken up earlier
profession but when you're in the
beginning stages of your Dean you don't
want to keep knocking yourself off so
tell yourself you know I'll handle that
I'm waking up I'm not missing Fajr so
same not with your music and everything
stop it in stages
even if you're doing uh you're listening
to it let's say usually listen to it
three hours a day listen to it for an
hour a day and then replace it maybe
with music which isn't as bad if you're
listening to music because modern day
music is quite
um
bad
um replace it with different types of
music whereby it's it's a lesser level
um of evil and toxicity and then replace
it maybe with Nasheed and then slowly
slowly
um until the Quran and other things into
it and um again just take it as slowly
as possible because it is a constant
battle you may even find yourself you
know what you can stop um you can stop
um music this year and then you find
yourself three years down the line
because some habits are really built
into you may go to a shopping mall and
you hear this one song that really hit
you um back um in your jahiliya and then
you it hits you back and you may end up
listening to that song that night and
that's what happens you're constantly in
a battle so again just look at it from a
positive outlook and just take things um
day by day inshaallah
beautiful advice I know bro did you want
to add and challenge the conversation
yeah yeah I would add this bit that I I
spoke to his brother with when I was in
Thailand and the year mentioned that
when you listen to the Quran
or even the sheets but primarily the
Quran it's like
it is very nurturing for your soul on
like such a deep level and the only way
you're truly aware of this is if you're
mindful if you're just aware of like
what's going on inside of you how you
feel especially after the fact after
you've finished listening to the Quran
the rest of the day and then he's like
when you listen to music like in the
moment in life it might feel amazing
because you have the dopamine going
through you it might sound amazing like
you might be really hooked to it because
it has that beat that's smacking but
it's like after
when you when you pay attention in your
Mindful and you're aware of how you feel
you don't feel nurtured if anything you
feel depleted and you actually want more
of it
subhanallah is crazy bro so I guess the
only thing that I would say is just um
practice being mindful because that is a
skill as well
100 even like especially Target with you
know taqwa being mindful of Allah as
well because if you're mindful of Allah
you're also mindful of yourself because
you know that Allah is going to hold you
accountable for whatever you you know
you say and you do and so on and so
forth so that's a great Point Allah we
have a first Super Chat from Brother
Yousef Allah bless you our brother uh he
says have my first Friday uh at the
Masjid today alhamdulillah
is amazing that's amazing beautiful
I mean
um brother tanak says if I only
understood the words I would listen to
the Quran 100 times let me tell you
something the Quran a lot of the
language in the Quran is used again and
again so if you learn what those words
mean which won't take long to be honest
maybe a few months you will be able to
understand the Quran so take some time
and learn what the words in the Quran
mean and then listen to it and and get
the benefit and recite it inshallah as
well and receive the benefit uh this
whole like oh if only I had this if only
I had that for me could do this and that
is honestly very useless because it
makes you feel like there is no next
step for you that's not true the next
step is just learn what the words in the
Quran mean you just outlined it yourself
so inshallah go make that one of your
goals Insha'Allah and reap the benefits
of it
you know but since he says it like this
it kind of makes me question like what's
he listening to everything forward
what's he listening to music for he's
just listening to like okay survived
like hear what they're saying and stuff
like that if that's the case then what
the brother here said is 100 true you
know like start within the sheets
because you can definitely understand
what they're saying in the sheets
and then from there you just work your
way into the Quran little by little
inshallah inshallah now this is a good
question for you guys can you talk about
Nia intention when making I'm assuming
he meant changes
that's a good that's that's a good one I
like that one
um we as humans by default everyone has
an intention
how pure that intention is is a very
different circumstance and it's a very
different um situation but as of humans
everyone just has an intention just
naturally we can't really make an action
without an intention every single action
requires an intention and it has an
intention by default again whether the
um the intentions in Islamic intention
and non-islamic contention completely
different
um
a question however to make an intention
when it comes to change then one
um and I'm assuming here maybe he's just
asking from an Islamic point of view
then the the general advice would
obviously be that begin by making the
intention for Allah
and um from there
um make your intention very clear to
what you're doing obviously as well
because your intention towards something
is going to be your action towards it
too so like if I intend for example to
only go to the gym uh because
uh because I'm trying to lose weight
then what happens when I lose weight is
my intention's finished right now it has
a timer on it I'm I've lost my way I
don't need to go to the gym no more so
when you do make that intention for
change try get try giving an everlasting
effect by making that intention go
um as far as as far as you can and
that's why the best intention is just to
have it for the sake of Allah because
when you have it for Allah Allah Allah
is alive and will never die and that's
why that intention can never be
eliminated and that's why we're advised
to always make your intention for the
sake of Allah because that intention can
be renewed it can be there again and
again and again if I make an intention
limited to something kind of done yet
then when that limit reaches then that
intention also is removed
100 very beautifully said Allah Mubarak
um side note very quickly we have a
brother who's asking what in the sheets
are uh does anyone want to explain what
a Nasheed is
is kind of like
vocal music but not really music you
know they they use the the
they use the voice to almost mimic as if
it was an instrument but it's not really
mimicking the instruments fully fully
um and then you know they would either
maybe they would rhyme they would maybe
sing or they would just do like humming
or something like this
uh very beautiful of some of them very
beautiful 100 and just look up Islamic
Nation inshallah you'll be able to hear
it
um Amino asks uh what do you suggest we
listen to in the gym especially when I'm
trying to go for New PRS
I would say um go on I would say don't
you don't need anything to do that
just just introduce yourself at the end
of the day like I find so many different
people like I know people who listen to
Quran in the gym and they're just able
to focus on the qurama they do their gym
and everything and I think it's good to
obviously listen something to block if
you if especially if you're someone who
doesn't listen to me they always put
something in your ears because you can
always block out the music especially
with today's generation you can use
noise cancellation
but this like idea that you always need
something like even going back to the
question and the advice
um that Romney gave
um until I probably said we always say
this if or we always need something so
like that brother who spoke about the
Quran he said I need for example
essentially what you're saying is I need
to understand Arabic to understand the
Quran I need oh and in this case I need
a Nasheed or something to pump me or
some sort of uh pre-workout to give me
my PR is we always put ourselves in this
um place whereby I need something to get
me somewhere and a lot of the time you
don't need that thing a lot of the time
you don't need that particular thing and
we just create it
um in order for us to make excuses as a
way of you know what that's a good
reason why I didn't hit the pr today I
just couldn't hear the right note
and yeah yeah yeah 100 100 and I'm not
like an avid uh gym goer I'm not like a
gym head or anything maybe I'm a weird
guy but anytime even if I'm trying to
hit a new PR or whatever I just keep
telling myself Allah made you strong
Allah may do strong Allah created you to
be strong you know this is for Allah and
then push push push push and like that's
literally all I do I don't listen to
music I don't listen to anything
um but the brother here burst Clan says
you can use gymnast cheats there are
playlists on YouTube so even if you feel
like you need to listen to something
they're in the shoes as well
um now a really good question for uh
brother Abdullah
uh Z asks how do we apply for the
productivity athletes uh services please
and thank you
um
so what you usually do is I'll just get
a DM and from a DM sometimes yeah I'll
give a basic reply and then if the
person's really interested they'll come
back to me because I like to see my
service as a bit like a bit like a
doctor doctor doesn't go out there and
just say oh you have this and you have
that come to me the the doctor just has
people at his doorstep because the
people realize that they either need to
be diagnosed or they need some help so
you DM me and then if you're really
interested then I'll give you the sign
up form and from there we can discuss
but um as of now
um my particular course that I've just
launched is is currently full I'm the
last so I won't be able to take anyone
on but I am trying to release some
guides
so people who can't afford the course or
haven't made this cohort would have
something in the meantime to just give
them a guide in show Allah whereby you
can find the steps towards productivity
and then we'll just discuss the
different um steps that you can take to
come out of pretty much from Level zero
bomb level absolutely not productive to
someone in Charlotte to become
productive
and Insha'Allah insha Allah brother
Lambo says I used to produce beats and I
learned the different frequencies that
activate the dopamine receptors and
stuff causing addiction and feeling of
nostalgia attaching themselves to you
wallahi Sinister subhanallah 100 I think
there was a video we made about it a
long time ago maybe a year and a half
ago and it is very very deep a lot of
artists and producers they talk about
how you know they hit certain
frequencies and they make sure there are
certain frequencies in the music to get
you attached and hooked to it and
bobbing your head and dancing so it is
very very Sinister while the Quran is a
shifa it's a healing for us
for the world
yeah there used to be his artist his
name was a triple X Temptation yeah he
passed away but he said it you know he
revealed it that like when he makes
music he can control the frequency and
thereby control you through the
frequency he can make you feel sad if he
wants you to make to if he wants you to
feel sad if you make you feel happy if
he wants you to feel happy so it's
it's it's pretty crazy man it's pretty
crazy yeah it's bro I swear last night
I'm trying to reduce Tick Tock last
night I made a video on Tick Tock
responding to uh to somebody and I came
across one video and it just had a very
sad song in the background and I went to
bed and I realized I'm like I just felt
so depressed I felt so sad and I well I
didn't know why and I'm thinking about
it I'm like why do I feel this way
and then like it's it felt like the song
was slowly creeping in the back of my
head and I'm like it's because I listen
to a sad song bro every single time I
listen to something and it repeats more
than once
bro it's a sad song it makes me feel sad
it's about Allah it's it's crazy how
effective it is someone says after
canceling my Spotify subscription I had
no desire to listen to music uh as I
couldn't choose what to listen to this
is what helped me awesome
the more aware you become the more you
see like you know how you you became
aware and you're like brother I'm sad
like why the hell am I sad it's because
of this this little song I was playing
in the background bro but again like
there are other songs there's music out
there that like when you listen to it
it like it almost like starts stroking
your ego and it starts making your ego
like just want to come out more and like
just more dominant more dominant
stuff for a lot man and people don't
realize this
people do not realize this yeah
I don't think I don't think people want
people to realize this you know what I
mean I I think people want everyone to
fall into this delusion and not notice
how effective it is and and how
effective they are being which is very
very unfortunate but that's why we're
here alhamdulillah right we want to
inshallah make people aware and make
them conscious
the concept of cognitive dissonance like
some people I think I think this is just
common in society today and in fact it's
promoted in society
you you're so deep into a sin and
because you can't get yourself out of it
you start justifying the sin so you're
like you know what it's not as bad as
everyone says it's just the way they're
making it sound or even today and I
don't and I don't want to be and I say
this obviously with respect even today
when it comes to like obesity and that
because some people are not willing to
and this is obviously those who actually
uh have the option or ability to come
out of that they'll now what are they
doing today they're justifying obesity
and saying it's actually something
healthy and something okay and this is
what cognitive dissonance is is you know
the reality of something or you have a
particular goal but your actions don't
match that goal so because your actions
don't match the goal something has to
change either your actions or the goal
it's a lot easier to change your goal
than it is to change your actions
therefore instead of now me trying to be
fit is the goal the new goal is I need
to be obese and that's how you make it
make yourself feel temporarily good
because you know deep down you're never
gonna feel good that's what people do
today when whether it's music or other
things they're so deep in a sin it's
just like you know what the Sims not bad
no more it's not as bad I'm at least
doing something else and that's how
they'll pretty much just justify it
cerebral that's the society we live in
man
I mean look look at the people who uh
they have the thoughts of homosexuality
and then they at some point they start
to justify like oh this isn't that bad
you know like everyone in society is
also doing this uh we're not everyone
but most people in society are doing
this so and it's being promoted you know
like it's being pushed so hey maybe it's
actually something normal maybe it's
actually something beneficial
I don't know
foreign
ready to hop on
uh Indo says I just came uh I just came
in late to the discussion but Music
Works differently on each person it can
affect most positively and most
negatively on the type of music music
listen to I think for most people listen
to sad music they'll feel sad and happy
music they'll feel like happy or
whatever but um the main point is that
it affects you in a very I don't want to
say unnatural way because it has a weird
like connotation sometimes but uh
ultimately a negative way
I was just gonna say anything that
influences you uh like that in that
manner especially when a lot of the the
music Industries is just so dirty to be
frank
it can't be good yeah anything that's
not a necessity that feels like a
necessity like that
has a clear indication that it's like
harmful and that's why for example like
alcohol can't feel like a necessity if
you end up drinking it or other things
and people may argue oh but what about
snacks and drinks and that but
essentially your diet is a necessity you
need to eat and how you eat then there's
obviously that's a different
um question but yeah like music has this
abnormally addictive addictiveness to it
whereby you can just listen to it hours
on end and in fact most people who
listen I don't know if I I believe I saw
a study recently where I said those who
listen to um music I was on end is a
sign of the depression sign of sadness
sign of loneliness that this is how they
fed up their day it's just a way to
distract their thoughts because they're
not happy with their own thoughts so
they need something else in their head
and that's how they pretty much satisfy
themselves and that's why music in
general it's just this is this history
of it and this is where it leads people
to do it especially today no one could
justify music on any level because music
today if you look at just the lyrics of
what they're saying in fact when you
look at the rappers themselves who they
say our lyrics is just nonsense we just
say whatever because the people like and
people are going to pay me for it that's
what it is they said this is what the
people want we're going to give it but
wait we don't even think it makes sense
it is absolute nonsense you could maybe
argue give the argument maybe 10 20
maybe 50 years ago but in modern day
Society you can can't really justify
music that much
yeah 100 it's been Allah it's crazy how
we took such a long tangent on music
yeah I know there's I know there's one
brother who used to listen to music all
the time and
um this is what my
it's not a Muslim by the way so it I
can't say you know like all the Muslim
brother or something like this but he
had a girlfriend and every time he would
be eating
he was put music on
he would put music on and then one day
she noticed he told me that she noticed
him listen music every time that he ate
and then she had asked him like why do
you listen to music every time that you
eat and he didn't even know what to
reply
he didn't know what to say to this girl
but it's it's crazy it's again it's it's
a deeper underlying thing and he was
trying to run away from something trying
to distract himself from something
because clearly he's putting the music
on whenever he's by himself even if
she's he was in the vicinity or someone
else in the vicinity from what he told
me he would always put music on so he
wouldn't be by himself
that's crazy
yeah yeah subhanallah
um the brother uh just joined hamdullah
is actually on his way home so I'm going
to bring him up on the Stream inshallah
yo my brother Oscar we're live how you
doing my man I'm grateful assalamu
alaikum
assalam what are you driving right now
yeah okay how long till you get home
[Music]
eight minutes
eight minutes
okay it's up to you if you want you can
join again once you get home
right now man yeah right now let's do it
now let's do it now eight minutes you
never know what could happen yeah
this route so I'll tap in in eight
minutes but I'm excited I'm really
excited to to tune in and to say my
shahada I've been practicing like my
words and everything
just to be sure you do want you want to
come back in eight minutes or you want
to do it now
uh I'll come back in eight minutes
bro you you better say that on your lips
while you're driving then you don't know
what's gonna happen inshallah nothing
happens for you may Allah
well it's because I wanna like I'm more
uh like share a little bit of the story
of the background like how I came into
this and everything of course of course
all right we'll be here my brother will
wait for you inshallah all right
inshallah I'll get home safely and then
I'll
I don't know
all right we got inshallah another seven
eight minutes to uh to talk about
productivity so let's start rounding it
up again
um
for everyone who's struggling with being
productive
what are some of the the base notes
again just to reiterate
um everything goes back to your purpose
and your purpose will determine how far
you go and how far you want to do
something and then someone may argue to
me and say you know what oh it will be
leaving a loss so why isn't why isn't
everyone motivated
you can believe in something or you can
have a purpose in life and that is
obviously our purpose is to live for the
sake of Allah and then you'll find some
people motivated more than others that's
because some people are more connected
to that purpose so one thing is finding
a purpose and then so one is finding a
purpose and then two would be connecting
to that purpose and then once you
connect to that purpose then you can
start designing your life around it and
when you design your life around this
purpose make sure you understand this
purpose and focus if someone says oh
you're living for the sake of Allah then
why aren't you just in the Masjid all
day oh wow you're just doing those study
no as I said it sounds comprehensive and
it comes from many different angles and
let's just say your purpose right now is
to live for money then that person's
lifestyle will revolve around all their
routine and productivity will revolve
around that purpose so your purpose is
the main thing because you need the
reason why you get up in the morning or
you do what you're doing can't just say
you're going to the gym for the sake of
it like I said an intention is always
required for every action whether the
intentions for the sake of Allah or for
for your sake or for someone else to say
that's it
there always has to have an existing
intention so you need that purpose and
then after you have that purpose
obviously set yourself ghost and they'll
be too ambitious in the beginning
because you're really lazy you're trying
to come out being lazy just set yourself
basic goals that you know what I'm going
to be someone who hits the gym twice a
week and set yourself other basic goals
I may read a page a day in a book or
Harvard page a day or even a line of a
page a day and then set yourself a very
very uh simple routine that's not
amazing you sleep late you wake up late
you eat at specific times even if
they're not the best of times but as
long as you're following some form of
routine you're following your word and
then from following your word you can
now tweak it and begin to adjust
yourself in a manner which is more
disciplined and then from there you can
develop 100 very actually everyone in
the chat right now go and like just for
that beautiful summary because if you
missed the whole stream and all you got
was that inshallah that should be enough
for you to start improving your life and
yourself and being more productive
Insha'Allah but one note I want to make
is oh sorry I don't know do you want to
add something no I had a question but by
all means bro I don't know Bismillah so
a lot of people actually one brother
comment didn't may Allah bless you uh
think that the key is to be motivated
motivation but unfortunately that is a a
utopic belief that doesn't actually
exist there's no one that's always
motivated
um rather what is more important is that
people are disciplined and when it comes
to discipline obviously it's a lot more
difficult because discipline is
basically doing what you need to do when
you don't want to do it and or or
there's something else you actually
really want to do like if you really
want to watch a movie or play video
games but you know you need to do your
assignment
a lot of people just end up playing
games and don't do their assignment out
of laziness or they procrastinate say
I'll do it later but the most important
thing that will help I think with
discipline and this is something I tell
the brothers in my sessions all the time
is to focus on why as soon as you
understand why you're doing something it
changes everything let's take that same
scenario why am I going to do my
assignment because if I don't I'm gonna
fail my parents are going to beat me
Loki right I'm gonna fail I'm gonna set
myself back I'm gonna have to redo the
course I'm gonna have to go to summer
school uh it doesn't look good I'm gonna
feel more negative about myself I'm
gonna feel like a failure blah blah blah
it's gonna affect my grade whatever it
might be and ask why am I going to play
video games
whatever answer you come up with I
promise it's not going to be enough and
you're gonna be like you're going to
feel this urge okay let me go finish my
assignment understanding why is the most
important thing when it comes to
discipline inshaallah
no no I definitely agree the equation of
when it comes to motivation as well yeah
the equation people just don't
understand the root of everything and I
think when you understand it you're like
okay this makes sense and I'm willing to
do this it's action without emotion so I
just have to do this like let's say you
want to start your YouTube you just do
it not because you're motivated you're
you're in the beginning your the reality
is you're a nobody when you start your
YouTube your Instagram no one knows you
you're just gonna do it because you feel
like you know what this is my path this
is what I'm choosing to do then it's
repetition you have to repeat it with no
emotion again so you're going to the gym
you're not seeing results for the first
couple of months you're not seeing the
results in the first maybe couple of
weeks of your
um content creation then after that
motivation comes from results so you
have to do actions repetition results
action repetition results equals
motivation and if you know how to use
that equation for your benefit then
you're always essentially kind of you
can kind of call it a motivation hack
that you kind of be motivated because
you know how now things work if I just
do an action and I repeat it and I get
success from it I'm going to be
motivated because no one ever gets an
award and doesn't feel motivated after
like Leslie your objective is to get a
certain amount of followers or your
objectives is to get a certain amount of
people to enter Islam let's say right
now your objective was one person but
you've got two people you're like yo
what I'm doing is working I'm just going
to repeat this again and again or you
made a cake
um and your company that makes cakes for
people and you're seeing people come
back you're like I'm gonna make more
cakes initially you have no motivation
to make cakes because you don't know if
it's gonna work or not or you don't know
if your Dow is going to work or not so
it's not motivating in the beginning but
it becomes motivating when you see
results and results can only come if
you're willing to do things without
um emotion in the first place and this
idea that emotions are required to do
anything is completely a fallible
idea completely because if we reacted on
our emotions all the time the world
would be chaotic every time I'm angry I
break something every time I'm sad I
don't want to go to work every time I'm
upset um I don't want to speak to this
person you have to overcome your
emotions they're just there to fill
they're there to make us human and these
different emotions can benefit you but
they should never be the reason you make
a decision I could be completely upset
that I am that I'm someone's taking
something from me but that doesn't give
me now the right to take something from
someone else just because I feel like I
was done dirty I'm gonna go do someone
else's day I do not need any form of
emotion to help me with my decision what
I do need is a rational plan or a
rational
um a timetable whereby it tells me what
to do and if it's good for me I'm doing
it and if it's bad for me then I'm not
going to do it and simple as I do not
need any form of emotion to lead me to
my actions all I do need is a rational
action plan
[Music]
another question uh from earlier do you
remember what that was
yeah brother Abdullah would you say that
you were a
like a baby step individual kind of
person or would you say you're like all
the type person
can you repeat the question sorry
yeah yeah so I feel like there's two
personality types right there's like the
people who are all in like they want to
do everything all at once and they
usually burn out and then there's the
people who
um they're more like
like babysit like just consistency like
over time little by little little by
little little by little
you know what it's like these people
they don't they don't do as much
but they don't burn out you know they're
actually consistent with it
I say I'll try I'll do my best to be in
between both of those I feel like when
you take baby steps it's definitely good
and I think it all depends on your stage
so when you're beginning anything can
you're just a new beat anything always
take baby steps but then after that you
do need to speed up and I think like
when you have less followers you can
provide less content the minute you have
more followers you lose more followers
as you gain more followers and therefore
your speed needs to go up and that's the
same now with your business if I in the
beginning you can be slow when it comes
to producing um products and everything
but the slower you are then the more
likely your business will crash you need
to speed up as things go and speed
defies gravity so you always want to go
as much as you it's a bit like a plane
eventually a plane has to be at a
particular speed in order for it to
exist or in order for it to be in there
and you so I try to be in between you
don't want to go all in but nor do you
want to be someone who takes too much
baby steps you want to try to find the
Fine Line in between both of those so
then you're able to move fast enough
whilst also being able to see your next
move
the 100 but that's what you try to be
what are you like naturally if you want
to try anything
I used to be someone who was just all in
and I think that's just out of
excitement and also of being optimistic
I just believe that you can do things a
lot quicker than people say and I've
seen that for myself and then as I
started a business and now when you
manage things itself
you have to be in between so usually now
I'm closer to the baby side than the
bigger side more than anything because
you have to be so much more calculated
like you're you're dealing now with
people you're dealing with people's
money you're dealing with people's
agreement you're dealing with a lot more
on your shoulder than just going forward
and you'll be like you know what I'm
just gonna go all in to things you have
to be a lot more calculated and because
of that that's also just spread whether
it's gym whether it's um Sports I do
whatever it may be I always just go in
now just slowly and try to go from there
yeah I had the literally the same exact
path like I'm always I was always super
awesome optimistic I always
overestimated my abilities a lot
um which I think is a bit contrary to
what you said you said a lot of people
you know can actually do things faster
than they believe if I already correctly
me I was always like I'm gonna read like
11 books in like two hours and then I
I'm on page four and I'm like I'm not
gonna get anywhere close to it so I'm
always like let me go you know let me
dump and you know Dive In The Deep End
jump down in there and then I realized
how deep I am so I I did take a more
moderate approach and start taking step
by step and I think that there's a lot
of benefit in that inshaallah it's just
some for some Realms some areas in life
the steps are going to be bigger you
know sort of like if you're not a reader
at all then maybe the step is reading
two pages a day right but if uh you want
to work out and you're not like you're
you're you physically enjoy it then
maybe the stuff will be going four times
a week for like an hour and a half like
maybe that's more doable for you besides
this step I think depends on on who you
are
definitely
honestly man like I love the plane
analogy you gave
I love bless you bro like yeah you got a
lot of knowledge not a lot of wisdom as
well man
alhamdulillah
may Allah bless us all and increase our
soul nothing is uh achieved without
Allah
brother Youssef says you Brothers see
the
um Somalia I have not I don't know what
that is but my welfare trust is a very
good charity
um it's a pretty much hundred percent uh
charity policy so they don't take no
like admin fees or anything and they do
their best to be a swing so they I think
right now
um they have this uh
crisis there's a crisis in Somalia and
they're basically at the Forefront of
basically trying to sort out the crisis
so may Allah make everything easy in
Somalia because I I heard there's a lot
of I don't know if it's floodings or
there's just a lot of problems there
right now and they're suffering quite a
lot
may Allah make it easier for them is
this thing called it's uh
welfare Trust
so how's you guys routine
like um in general because you guys see
lawn about it especially recently you
guys um have to carry a channel like
this is not easy especially if the the
demand you guys must have and now I know
you guys probably what people may know
or may not know is that you guys
probably dealing with things in the
background the fact that you guys have
shahadas and everything going on in the
background probably means you guys are
probably getting questions from people
like from different angles oh I'm
suffering from this how will you guys
advice and it's probably a lot deeper
than you guys maybe initially expected
so how is life as well like kind of
changed from there and I know I'm not
the host but I just want to ask because
it's quite interesting I shot a lot like
what you guys are doing and um you guys
like went pretty much you can see is
there a terror very quickly masha'allah
and I don't blame the community as to
why they did that
it's a good question for sure to make to
summarize as much as possible for me
in terms of my routine it's pretty
it's pretty stable I'd say
um I work Monday to Friday and um we
record or we go live Wednesdays and
Thursdays I have two brother sessions on
the weekends and um those are like my
absolutely firm fixed things in my
schedule I will book The off meeting or
the off call or the off consultation
um and then anytime I have free time I
like to use it either to record a video
or to do some other kind of head or
respond to a comment or even make a tick
tock video once in a while and give
people some benefit
um but I honestly um a lot of the
background work for the channel like 99
when I say a lot I mean like 99 of the
background work is done by Fiats
yes yes
I mean I mean yeah I mean but we are
trying to create a Discord for um for
people who who have you know
considerations or or contentions or need
help or advice trying to make a Discord
inshallah to bring the community
together so make thought that that can
be done um successfully and efficiently
man I'm the same bro I'd say my routine
is very uh
it's very good alhamdulillah I try to do
all my work between like Fajr and over
time and then like between Dover and and
Maghrib like I'll try to just include
like either studies or working out
during that time I know it's a little
different for you because you were
saying you you work on the morning time
by the way Habibi well well
and
yeah and just finishing like my my whole
point is that uh
it's definitely hard man because it's
it's an Amana when you start you know
you start growing and people start
reaching out to you more and we might
become overwhelmed but it's like bro
it's it's so beautiful and it's it's
think about how much butter goes in
there that someone's reaching out to you
asking you a question for help
you know like that's a huge trust that's
a huge amount and like I'll be honest
man like I'm I have a very difficult
time trying to respond to each person
but
I'm doing that bro I'm very very blessed
very grateful and uh I just try to do my
best
may Allah bless it for you and your
whole team inshallah
I mean all right Bismillah so um Another
Blessing Allah has given us his brother
Oscar alhamdulillah giving us the honor
of um of helping him give uh take his
shahada live for everybody inshallah to
benefit from as well it's always a
beautiful Iman booster assalamu alaikum
my man how you doing I'm grateful well I
like walaikum salaam how are y'all
you're looking good my man you're
looking good thank you thank you okay so
I'm sure like maybe y'all are curious or
some of the viewers are kids like why is
he wearing a headdress you know and he's
not even Muslim yet okay there's a story
behind that too but I want to take my
shahada right now so I'm ready I'll take
it in Arabic first and then English all
right uh before we say the shahada I'm
just going to ask you six very quick
questions uh about like the tenets of
faith in Islam so first and foremost you
do believe that there's only one God
worthy of worship with no Partners or
Associates yes 100 and do you believe in
the angels of Allah 100 yes and do you
believe in the prophets and Messengers
that Allah has sent yes 100 and do you
believe in the revelations that Allah
has sent with the messengers like the
Torah the gospel and the Quran
yes and do you believe in decree Divine
decree or destiny from Allah
yes 100 and do you believe in life after
death in the day of judgment
yes and yes 100 Allah Allah bless you
immensely and with that being said
can you guys see my screen yes all right
just repeat after me in Arabic
and LA
and LA ilaha
illallah
Anna
Anya
muhammadan muhammaden
Abu duhu abduhu wa
rasulo rasulu now repeat after me in
English I bear witness I bear witness
that there is none worthy of worship
that there's nothing but worship
none worthy of worship non-worthy of
worship except for Allah except for
Allah and I bear witness and I bear
witness that the prophet Muhammad that
the prophet Muhammad is the servant and
messenger of Allah is these servant and
messenger of Allah Allah
welcome to Islam our beautiful brother
Oscar alhamdulillah how you feeling my
man
grateful and excited
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah so why don't
you go ahead and tell us about your uh
your beautiful story in coming to Islam
yeah first I want to give a shout out to
Allah Allah Akbar and then second I want
to give a shout out to my wife for
allowing me and helping me like give me
the space to tune into the live because
we have two sons and they're two under
two so like it takes more than one
person to definitely take care of them
so I want to give a shout out to her and
then
the story is I've been studying Islam
for like since 2018 but it's not the
Islam that I'm tuning into now it's the
Islam that has been
I guess you could say watered down or
remixed because here in
North America before the United States
it was the 13 colonies and before the 13
colonies it was the Americas before the
Americas it was Northwest of Mexico
and the so-called Indians of here were
not really called Indians that Indian
name was given to them in replacement of
their original name which were the Moors
the Moors the Moorish Empire used to run
majority of the world including over
here in in the Americas so that's why I
wear this turban or I wear a headdress
because sometimes I wear a fast
and first I I did it just to remind
myself and remind other people around
them that where we come from and the
original indigenous people how they used
to look how they used to wear so I would
do that but then after I noticed that
declare because like the reason why I
mainly was attracted to it it had a lot
of answers for the questions that I was
seeking but then once I've noticed that
most of these answers
after cross-referencing it they weren't
accurate in my opinion therefore like uh
because the reason
many people like I don't know if you've
heard about the Moors and like the like
the rise of the Moors or things like
that here in the in the states
no I'm not familiar yeah so many of the
Moors including in Cana land AKA Canada
because Canada used to be called Cano
land so a lot of the more they like to
study history and they like to identify
the country with its older name with the
original name instead of the new
corporate name
and
many of the Moors would say declare your
nationality because nationality is the
order of the day and I'm like what is
declare your nationality mean so I did
further research and that was back in
2018 and then I found found a prophet
named Prophet abujra Ali who
surprisingly he wrote well he didn't
write he prepared the circle seven Holy
Quran have you guys heard of that
uh no so it's not the same as the Quran
that Prophet Muhammad wrote it's a lot
smaller and it's more specific to a
group of people of here in the in the
northwest
or in the so-called United States and
prophetra Ali he
wrote or prepared that book at age 40
just like Prophet Muhammad wrote the
book The Holy Quran okay can I can I
just jump in quickly please yeah yeah go
ahead so
when um
when you say he's a prophet do you mean
like a prophet of God like the prophet
Muhammad and all that or what do you
mean when you say prophet
what I mean with profit he was he was
sent because uh the Moors they believe
in Allah as well but it's it's like they
kind of contradict themselves and that's
why I kind of slowed down entertaining
that information because there was a few
contradictions so it is like a prophet
from Allah because he did come to
free the so-called black people by
letting them know hey if you nationalize
and you know and you accept the law as
your God and if you accept that you're
not black and you do have a nationality
you will not have uh you won't be in
trouble with with the jurisdiction of
the United States
yeah so are you talking about like uh is
this kind of the like the Nation of
Islam rhetoric information
completely different the Nation of Islam
I don't participate with them I think
they are instead of disrespecting them I
think they're just through a hard
learning curve all of them they're going
through a hard learning curve because I
don't want to disrespect them in any way
so I don't know I never entertain that
you know especially and ever entertain
them or followed him or put him on a
pedestal so it's different from that
okay so I just I just want to make sure
that this like this Moorish kind of
Islam and all that stuff you don't
believe that there is a prophet after
the prophet Muhammad peace upon him
right so now I said Prophet Muhammad as
the only true prophet and they saw to
Islam and uh like the last and final
prophet in messenger of Allah correct
correct perfect because just to be clear
for like everyone you and the viewers we
believe in the prophets like Abraham
Noah Moses Jesus uh peace and blessings
be upon all of them and the prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings to be upon
him but we believe that the prophet as
Allah says in the Quran is the Seal of
the prophets and in another recitation
of the same Ayah the last of the
prophets so and there are unfortunately
a few different groups that are trying
to say oh this person the prophet that
person Prophet
very clearly as Muslim as Muslims that
the prophet sallam is Allah messenger of
Allah so when you know after learning
all this stuff and saying that there are
contradictions and that stuff when did
you come to you know true Islam
I started studying it consistently for
like the past month or so and the the
funny thing is because I I would
entertain the true Islam like a year ago
but I wasn't really
focusing on it 100 because me and
including many other Moors or declared
Morris would be like oh that's dogmatic
religion we shouldn't be doing that the
higher self is is the god and your lower
self is the devil like you are your own
devil you are like like that's where the
contradictions were coming from you know
and and that's that's when I started to
you know just connect the dots and I was
like okay like if if nationality is the
is the order of the day and many of
these mores were declared to Moors are
saying that
like this is the true Islam but then I
then I started to read the Holy Quran
last year because I I asked for a copy
and then I started to see differences
actually took a photo with my son with
my first son like me reading the Quran
to him because I want to show that photo
to him when he gets older and that was
last year so I was like dabbling last
year but then I started consistently
studying it like a month and I would
just watch y'all's Channel when y'all
were like around 80k subscribers how to
watch other channels another channel is
a the skeptical Muslim I really like his
channel
the Muslim skeptic Daniel yeah him yeah
yeah yeah I really like his his channel
then I would watch uh Muhammad uh hijab
I think yeah yeah so like I really like
how he
uh represents himself and represents
Islam so that's what attracted me more
too so now like I I stopped listening to
music even before I send my shahada
because
I used to listen to everything like it
would be country pop hip-hop classic
hip-hop classical music metal Rock like
everything because I like I didn't have
a specific genre I was open to
everything and now I don't listen to
anything because it's it's a lot better
I'm able to focus more but if I am
listening to anything it would be to
debates it would be the recitation of
the Quran or it would be y'all's Channel
when y'all interview different people so
that's what I really listen to more you
know because I really want to prepare
myself before I took my shahada then I
would uh then wearing the headdress is
going circling back to like what I
mentioned earlier
this year in the beginning of this year
I made the intention and a promise to
myself that I'm aware of my headdress as
much as I can even at work only to to
make a
promise for myself that I'ma represent
myself and the indigenous Mexicans that
are from Mexico to let them know like
hey this is how we used to look this is
how we used to be because the original
mexican that are not show or taught in
school like in the history books is uh
needs to be taught needs to be reminded
and if you look at the Virgin Mary she
looks Muslim herself covering her body
from head to toe and if you look and you
Google different photos of like Mexico
from the 1700s or 1600s most of them
look Muslim so that's why I wear the
headdress you know and if I'm if I don't
wear the turban I wear a Fest or if I
could wear it both sometimes I put the
tournament and the face on
Allah
Affairs uh they call it uh in Turkey
it's like a red headdress where ah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah then it has a tassel
it's it's with the Shriners and the
Freemasons wear but the difference of
mine in theirs is my tassel is not
pinned and it it's not marked meaning
I'm free so that's it's my right to wear
that fence but with Freemasons and
Shriners the reason why it's marked and
their tassel is pinned is because
they're slaves to their Master which
were the Moors because a lot of the
Moors
top which a lot of the boys were Muslim
by the way just so y'all know for the
record they were the original Islam like
the Islam that I took my shahada with
they were those Muslims and they would
teach mathematics Linguistics
um and many other things to the
Europeans so they could bring the
Europeans out of the darkness and into
the light you know so they could be
civilized and everything so that's why
there's this Mark and their tassel was
pinned because they only have a limited
degree of knowledge and talking about
Freemasons I did look up some fun facts
that George Washington he didn't believe
in the Trinity and Thomas Jefferson he
bought uh well he he either he bought or
he was gifted to him I think it was
gifted to him a holy Quran uh 11 years
before he wrote the Constitution or
before he created the Constitution so
Islam had a lot to do with the
Constitution that we have today it was
heavily influenced and George Washington
too he allowed his Muslim slaves I mean
this sounds wrong but it's just a
historical fact he allowed his Muslim
slaves to work and to buy themselves out
of being out of slavery so they could be
free and George Washington would would
also learn Arabic from them or learn
some of the Islamic principles from them
and that's why he gave him more freedom
compared to the other slaves from
different religions or different
nationalities
this is real like you have actual like
yeah you don't have to believe me you
you could no I'm not questioning you but
I'm not I'm not Christian like that I'm
just wondering that's what I like about
the Muslim Community or or about Islam
is that we have to look for facts you
know before we actually take it uh as a
fact you know and that's what I really
like about that too I like challenging
because that's how you grow like Allah
says in the Quran like the only way you
can know your true strength is by
testing you know just by testing
yourself or by passing the test or even
if you fail the test you have another
opportunity to to improve and majority
of my life I've always been about
self-improvement but there's like a year
or two or three that I did fall off and
I was like pessimistic I was like you
know what there's no point in improving
like this but I've recently been
disciplined and waking up at 5am every
day even though I go to sleep sometimes
at 12 because I have two two children
two under two one is a year and a half
and another one is like about to be a
month or he's probably a month
I barely get any sleep but I discipline
myself to wake up at five because I want
to start my day before I go to work I
don't want to just wake up and go to
work you know and yeah
we're just talking about these things
yeah literally we just we the whole like
last hour and a half or last hour we
were talking about all this stuff's
trying a lot yeah yeah it's beautiful
it's lining up and and I'm big on
discipline I mean I may sometimes I may
be too harsh like for like for my wife
or for my cousins or anyone that's close
to me like you gotta discipline yourself
and because I don't tolerate like uh
um uh what's the word procrastination
but I do procrastinate myself and that's
why I I get caught up in my own thinking
because I'm like okay I don't tolerate
uh uh like other people's lacking but I
slack a little bit sometimes you know so
like okay I just have to lead by example
and save my energy save my
my opinion until I actually started
applying 100 of discipline and stopped
procrastinating 100 yeah I don't know if
that's possible is that possible to stop
procrastination 100 percent
um I'd say extremely difficult
you know what it's theoretical unless
like you've actually been through
yourself but still regularly speaking I
think I think it would be uh granted the
right situation is put into place like
if you have a man and he has like
several wives and several children I
highly doubt this man's gonna be
procrastinating
right yeah because uh because I like
well I've been told from many people
that I'm hard on myself like I have to
like be softer to myself but I really
don't see that you know like I can't
really comprehend that because it's
coming from my own perspective but I
really can't see that however uh
circling back to the story so after it's
consistently studying like a month and a
half consistently back to back watching
different debates
listening to the Quran and reading it
I'm like okay like I have a few
questions about a few things but I know
I'm gonna get the answers the more I
read the Quran you know so like because
all the answers are there because if I
just ask y'all or someone else that's
just me procrastinating on reading the
Quran you know instead of looking for
the answers myself yeah 100 actually on
that note we have a super chat brother
Mo says welcome to Islam Oscar I
strongly urge you to study the Quran and
the Sera which is the life of the
Prophet sallallahu alaihi peace be upon
him these brothers can help you with
sources study circles Etc may Allah
bless you and your family with knowledge
and guidance
I'm aware of that word so sure
and brother Noor says assalamualaikum
Brothers I'm from Somalia and love you
all for the sake of Allah may Allah
Grant
I mean
before we end off this stream uh I think
alhamdulillah is a beautiful overlap now
between actual gas brother Abdullah and
brother Oscar
um so brother Abdullah do you have any
advice for the brother you know just
coming into Islam
um
forgive me for the silence I don't want
to be abrupt in giving them advice um in
this particular regard directly
um too quickly
um
the advice of like the Messiah
is always to just to uh to take things
obviously as slow as possible and try to
focus more on definitely the five daily
prayers more more important than
anything and try to build that love and
connection towards your religion as much
as you can
um but obviously as the brother advised
the through the super chat through the
seat of Muhammad because the more you
know him
um the more you love him and this is
just inevitable you have you just love
him because the more you understand him
and also the Quran because the speech of
Allah is the greatest speech
um to ever be revealed to Mankind and
it's perfect and it doesn't have
anything missing from it and while
saying that as well is
and this is a general productivity
concept and this is just a general like
Islamic concept as well is that don't
try act too much try remove more and
what I mean by that is we should all
reflect on our lives and think what bad
habits do I have that I can remove so I
can make spaces for new habits sometimes
what happens is we try to add habits and
that's what actually reduces our
discipline because we have other bad
habits which cause friction between
these habits so for example like let's
say you want to wake up in the morning
forget trying to wake up early in the
morning focus on trying to stop sleeping
late and then naturally you wake up in
the morning so if you can take that
concept and then apply it to your
religion and think you know what like
you said masha'allah you've already
taken the step to not listen to music
that's going to open now the doors to
Quran because some people what they do
is they'll try this into Quran but then
they listen to music and that takes them
away from the Quran whereas if they just
stop listening to music they'll be
forced or they'll love to listen to the
Quran so if you do that towards the
beginning of your journey what you're
doing is purifying yourself and making
space for all of the worship and all of
the knowledge that you're going to
um partake in sha Allah and doing it
that way will not feel as overwhelming
as trying to research so many things
um from from so many different angles
and that would just generally be like my
advice to people whether in the
productive life or just in your Islamic
life which is also a productive life as
well so
yeah thank you
you're welcome
and that's that advice does not just go
for brother Oscar it's also for me for
on him for all you guys at home
inshallah and I'm sure for brother
Abdullah himself
may Allah bless all the people who
attended inshallah do you guys have any
last words for the people watching
before we end the Stream
no
that's it five all right for me and I
was just gonna say Obviously thank you
guys for um for having me on your stream
um for as well like being good
companionship obviously this is whilst
you guys interview me at the end of the
day this is also companionship between
us
um alhamdulillah we've built um a small
Bond and it's the beginning of abundance
and also in two different countries
alhamdulillah were being brought
together by the benefit of the internet
and uh inshallah everyone has benefited
from uh from this Amela bless your work
and increase you guys in goodness and
keep you firm upon your sincerity
because one of the hardest things to do
in this uh Road of yours is to be as
sincere as you can and both for myself
and yourselves
um so yeah just keep up the hard work
insha Allah may Allah bless you all with
what's best for you and protect you from
that which may harm you
I mean for you as well I do want to give
a shout out to fire because he's the one
that like uh messaged me and everything
so I want to give a shout out to fire
definitely definitely he's up now
blessing for organizing everything can
be in like a backbone for you guys as
well
for the entire chat if y'all are
watching right now y'all misfired spam
the chat section with hashtags
we're gonna make this a thing until he
comes back inshallah inshallah and
with that being said
all right